Hollywood lined up lots of high-profile horror
projects in 2017, from a revival of the Saw
franchise to a creepy new take on Stephen
King's It.
And in 2018, there seems to be plenty more
where that came from.
Strap in, because the future looks dark in
the best, possible way.
A Quiet Place
Plot details for A Quiet Place are being kept
tightly under wraps in advance of its April
2018 release, but screenwriters Scott Beck
and Bryan Woods have been on an upward trajectory
ever since they earned a top fifty spot in
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck's Project Greenlight
competition.
While their 2015 debut feature Nightlight
wasn't particularly well-received, their spec
script for this new project was good enough
to be purchased outright by Paramount — and
to attract Hollywood power couple John Krasinski
and Emily Blunt, who will be onscreen together
for the first time… unless you count this
Oscar-worthy performance on late night TV.
"You're not married anymore."
"John?"
Slender Man
Veteran TV director Sylvain White will helm
this adaptation of one of the most well-known
internet memes of all time.
The Slender Man has stalked the Web since
2009, when a Photoshop contest produced a
picture of the tall, thin, faceless stalker
of hapless children.
Sony/Screen Gems has slated Slender Man for
release on May 18, 2018.
And while details are scant on the film's
plot, lovers of creepy internet memes have
a pretty good idea what to expect.
Meg
Meg is a joint American/Chinese production
whose title doesn't give away a whole lot
— unless you know that "Meg" is short for
Megalodon, a giant prehistoric shark.
The film's international cast will portray
a deep-sea research team that comes nose-to-nose
with the terrifying creature when their submersible
craft is disabled.
Jason Statham stars as a Navy captain and
expert diver, with Rainn Wilson and Ruby Rose
in supporting roles.
The Chinese lead, Li Bingbing, is a veteran
actress who you might recognize from the most
recent installments of the Transformers and
Resident Evil series.
We'll have to wait until August 10, 2018 to
get a look at Meg — but that look will be
in 3D IMAX and will involve Jason Statham
fighting a giant shark, so it should be worth
the wait.
Cadaver
Shay Mitchell makes the jump from TV's Pretty
Little Liars to big-screen horror with Cadaver,
an intriguing project also starring Castle's
Stana Katic.
Mitchell stars as a morgue technician and
disgraced former cop, whose late-night shifts
take a turn for the sinister when she receives
a badly brutalized corpse.
Kinda like this:
"You'll see human heads without bodies…"
Audiences will have to wait until August 24,
2018 to get a look at Cadaver.
But director Diederik Van Rooijen is already
onto his next project — he's been tapped
to handle an upcoming remake of Alfred Hitchcock's
classic The Birds.
Halloween
Reboots of classic horror franchises haven't
exactly been cinematic gold in recent years,
with new installments of Nightmare on Elm
Street and Friday the 13th leaving fans wondering
if these franchises were better off dead.
Since Rob Zombie remade Halloween in 2007
and did a sequel to it in 2009, we understand
if you're not too excited about a new Halloween,
but here's the thing, you should be, for one
key reason.
"This is my moment!"
Eastbound & Down star Danny McBride and producer
David Gordon Green came together to work on
the new film, which will serve as a sequel
to the first two films:
"I think tension is what it's all about.
Keeping that tension and keeping people's
stomach in knots."
Michael Myers will return to theaters on October
19, 2018, just in time for the scariest night
of the year.
The Strangers 2
The Strangers was a surprise hit in 2008,
and not many fans were expecting the second
installment — which was announced way back
in 2009 — to actually see the light of day.
But a decade after the first film hit theaters,
it's coming, with original director Johannes
Roberts and writer Bryan Bertino on board.
Christina Hendricks leads the cast of the
film, which has an as-yet-undetermined release
date in 2018.
What we do know is that it reportedly takes
place at a trailer park in the middle of nowhere
during a power outage, where an appearance
by the malevolent Sackhead and Pin-Up Girl
would definitely be something to scream about.
Nosferatu
The Witch is widely considered to be among
the scariest films of 2015, a unique and ambitious
debut by director Robert Eggers.
And for his follow-up, Eggers isn't scaling
back on his ambition.
He'll be helming a remake of the seminal 1922
horror classic Nosferatu, an undertaking only
attempted once before — in 1979, by acclaimed
German filmmaker Werner Herzog.
Eggers is a lifelong fan of the original film,
and has even mounted a stage production, twice.
It's safe to say the remake is in very good
hands — and if The Witch is any indication,
fans might be in for the creepiest vampire
flick in years.
Abruptio
Buffy the Vampire Slayer's James Marsters
stars in this intriguing film, playing a down-on-his-luck
regular Joe who wakes up one morning with
a bomb implanted in his neck.
And there's one hell of a twist:
"It's the sickest stuff you can imagine, but
they're all gonna be puppets."
That's right: all the film's roles will be
performed by life-sized, realistic latex puppets.
And it's got a hell of a supporting cast,
including comedian-turned-horror mastermind
Jordan Peele.
Abruptio will hit theaters sometime in 2018
— and we can only hope we're ready.
Winchester
Now this looks really cool, Winchester is
inspired by the true and very bizarre story
of firearm heiress Sarah Winchester, whose
mansion is the stuff of legend.
"A house shrouded in mystery and speculation.
A house that has been the source of one of
the most unusual legends in California history."
Winchester supposedly believed that the ghosts
of people killed by her family's firearms
would haunt her forever — unless she never
stopped building.
Rotating shifts of carpenters worked on the
mansion until Winchester's death in 1922,
creating an endless series of rooms, nooks
and hallways.
"There’s odd little corridors that maybe
once went somewhere… but the unusual never
really stops in this house."
The upcoming film is a supernatural period
piece, written and directed by identical twins
Peter and Michael Spierig, who were behind
the 2009 sci-fi/horror thriller Daybreakers.
But key to the project is the casting of Helen
Mirren in the lead role, bringing the kind
of acting chops that can elevate any material.
Winchester is slated for release on February
23, 2018.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!